I gotta ask you about a friend of yours
Tracy Morgan because he's a friend of
mine as well and I just I know you've
worked with him on the last OG and it's
just he's this guy who I if if Tracy
wasn't famous I couldn't explain him to
anybody is that is that true I just
talked to Tracy the other day so I
called him just on some random hey bro
checking in you know
he just goes like you've been having a
conversation instead
it don't make no sense you know
it's just the way that it is you know
yeah yeah
you know you gotta I agree I agree I
agree 100 percent
it's a lot of money for fish yeah what
oh he's oh he's really into the fish oh
he's into the fish are crazy I'm telling
you this is a true story well during uh
kovid when everyone was we were doing
the interviews and uh you did people
would be on zoom and I'm talking to him
and he's talking and being crazy and
that's crazy enough just trying to talk
to the man is insane talk to Tracy
Morgan have a conversation with him
saying and then a barracuda swam behind
him and I was like what the and he was
like that's my fish tank and it's not a
fish tank it's a fish tank the size of
this studio it's in his house yes and
it's got sharks and barracudas it's like
he's a James Bond villain who's you know
what I mean you look up and it's like
groups of kids doing field trips through
there it's so very odd thing like it's
such a big fish tank in someone's house
you're like is that what hot Academy
kids
[Laughter]
yeah it's not just the Barracuda it's
some crazy unique Barracuda right that
he's found you know off this
shores of seashell or somewhere
[Laughter]
you're like what he's like yo yo that's
there that's that's my ring that's my
man's right there
yes
but he get everybody pregnant
he was on the podcast he did a podcast
in New York City and he came on and he I
hugged him when he came out and he
smelled I got a thought he like he had
this powerful cologne on I'm like what
is that and he said it's dupe and you
know the way he holds it for a long time
and he looks at the whole crowd and he's
just was telling a stoop it's Jupe and
he made half the segment about Jews and
Joop was delighted yeah because no one's
talked about Jupe in a long time exactly
yeah but he gets into something and he
can make yeah you can barely get that in
the middle of the mall nowadays well we
they sent us a crate he sent you a box
it's a classic though it still was one
of those ones like chorus and Joop and
Lagerfeld those were the ones we grew up
on
smelling great and groovy yeah Obsession
I put a little on and uh didn't say
anything and I went home to my wife yes
and uh
no it didn't go well of course
she made me yeah check into a hotel
you're not a Cologne guy I'm not a
Cologne guy my own odor that's tough
enough
I smell like onions and fear
Conor O'Brien needs a friend is brought
to you by T-Mobile from listening to
your favorite podcast while driving
cross country to listening at home
T-Mobile helps you stay connected I
wonder what people's favorite podcast is
oh I've got some ideas actually it's one
idea yeah you'll figure it out T-Mobile
is America's largest and fastest 5G
Network you can have seamless video
calling oh that's good streaming your
favorite podcast I'm not gonna say which
one it is yeah downloading apps games
boy you know what a gamer I am you're
such a gamer play starbursters yeah or
realm of zados
you can watch your favorite TV episodes
classic Conan new Conan old Conan
mid-season Conan as long as it's Conan
oh no find out more at t-mobile.com
Network fastest based on media and
overall combined 5G speeds according to
analysis by UCLA of speed test
intelligence data for q1 2023 c5g device
coverage and access details at
t-mobile.com
you know I heard you say once which I
really liked you were talking about how
um with the exception of that guy who
you needed to knock out in order to uh
get your start and show business that is
a rare exception for you because you you
don't root against other comedians
you're happy for them to do well because
your theory has always been you know
it's like that that concept that a
rising tide lifts all the boats yeah
you're rooting for other people to do
well you think it's going to expand the
space uh yeah for sure I think you know
I mean because you know creativity is is
definitely that like if you're around
creative people I mean just like this
Vibe you know like the energy lifts up
you start saying things or doing things
that you would never have thought of
before so you know it's great to be
around like people that are that that
they could be young or older but they
bring in a good vibe and good energy
then you know that's usually gonna
inspire you to to go higher you know so
that's why I like that that's why kind
of love that attitude of like when
people were killing it or they bring
something new to the game or something
like that you're like yo let's go I like
that you know yeah yeah I think that's a
great attitude uh I'm gonna pretend to
have the same attitude I like it no no I
actually I really do I I like to root
for people and it's and it's just like
the in the time that I've known Kevin
Hart he went from being you know this
guy that would come on our show to uh
he's I think he's basically has the
gross national product of like a a
fairly well-to-do country now you know
like he's like it's he's everywhere he's
in every commercial he's in every single
commercial and they just switch out what
he's holding he doesn't even know they
take out one credit card and they put a
different one in uh but
um he has such a positive energy and I
get I always get energized when I'm
around him yeah because it's coming from
a good place he just uh oh he this is
what he loves and that's what's so great
I think that a lot of people too like
can Heaven literally is one of those
people like you go uh you know he's the
same person that's when you kind of knew
him back when yep you know even though
he's like extremely successful and
really rich he really is a very
approachable and and regular dude and
he'll go right into wait what did you
say that's like he's he's right
there and connected yeah uh he starts
giving me about like what I'm
wearing immediately in this very
friendly in touch way whereas as we all
know people that have hit it and then
something happens it's like they go
behind a bubble forms around them oh
yeah yeah I mean it seems to be less of
that I guess probably nowadays with you
know with social media the opportunity
excuse me the opportunity where people
kind of know you a little bit more but I
think you're right I think that it used
to be being a star meant you had to be a
little more reclusive you had to give
off this Persona of I'm kind of other
than you know I'm a little bit more than
the average person but now I think you
know if you do that to somebody you know
like at a damn Starbucks then you know
you big time them then you know they can
light you up all day on you know next
you know it just starts a wave you like
no I just didn't see you you know I had
my sunglasses on or whatever but you
know I think you gotta you got to
protect yourself as a human being like
you know I was always one when my kids
were little and I was a stickler for you
know like making sure that people
understood I was with my children like
just try to get at some get at some
Merit guys like it's not that I don't
want to take pictures with you or you
know but you know I'm with my little
kids like you know I'm not gonna I find
that mostly people respect that for the
most part and if they don't that's
telling you something about them right
exactly but you know you're the target
you know so that's the hard thing you
know until I turn that Target on you
Jesus what happened yeah you totally
switched yeah you all right what
happened you off your meds yeah